Olá, pessoal, tudo bem? Hoje eu vou
responder uma pergunta que eu recebi
aqui no Instagram. Doutor, vale a pena
fazer esse exame de microbiota
intestinal? E olha, a resposta não é
simples como sim ou não. Eu vou contar
para vocês o caso real de uma paciente
minha. Vamos chamá-la de Maria para
mostrar quando faz sentido e quando é
jogar dinheiro fora. Primeiro vamos
falar de grana, porque esse exame não é
barato. No Brasil você vai desembolsar
entre 2 e R$ 4.000. É isso mesmo que
você ouviu. Dá para comprar até um
celular. Então a pergunta é: vale esse
investimento? Bom, deixa eu te contar
uma verdade que muita gente não sabe. A
grande maioria dos testes microbioma
disponíveis hoje utilizam diferentes
técnicas e focam em taxonomia. A maioria
fornece pouca informação para propósitos
diagnósticos ou prognósticos. É como
tirar uma foto do seu intestino sem
saber interpretar o que está vendo.
Atualmente não existe um microbioma
intestinal saudável ou normal,
definitivo, que possa prever
confiavelmente se uma pessoa vai
desenvolver ou não uma doença
específica. Cada pessoa tem um
microbioma único, tipo uma impressão
digital intestinal. O que é normal para
você pode ser anormal para mim. Agora
vem o caso da Maria que ilustra
perfeitamente quando o exame pode valer
a pena. Ela chegou no meu consultório
depois de anos sofrendo com sintomas
intestinais, já tinha tentado de tudo,
dietas, probióticos, remédios, nada
resolvia. Gastou uma fortuna em
tratamentos que não funcionavam porque
ninguém sabia exatamente qual era o
problema. Quando fizemos o gim dela,
descobrimos coisas que jamais teríamos
descoberto com exames convencionais. A
querermância homocenifila estava zerada,
a fecalobactérium praites quase
inexistente, peptídeo de glúten
altíssimo, mesmo ela jurando que não
comia glúten, era aveia sem glúten que
ela comia todo dia causando problema.
Mas aqui vem um grande problema. Nenhum
dos testes de microbioma foi
completamente validado para sua
utilidade em avaliar a saúde intestinal
geral. Nenhum é aprovado pela FDA. Nos
Estados Unidos, uma das agências mais
reguladas do mundo, esse exames não tem
aprovação oficial para diagnósticos.
Um consenso internacional recente,
envolvendo cientistas destacou que
laboratórios que comercializavam teste
de microbioma devem aderir a padrões de
alta qualidade e clientes devem estar
cientes da evidência atualmente limitada
para esses testes. Ou seja, até os
especialistas concordam que ainda
estamos engatinhando nessa área. Sabe o
que mais complica? Estudos mostram que
os nossos microbiomas podem mudar todos
os dias baseados nos alimentos que
comemos e vários outros fatores de
estilo de vida, incluindo exercício e
estresse. É como tirar uma foto de uma
festa, cada momento é diferente. O exame
que você faz hoje pode não refletir como
estava o seu intestino semana passada ou
como estará a semana que vem. Porém, no
caso da Maria, o exame valeu cada
centavo. Por quê? Ela já tinha tentado
tudo sem sucesso, tinha sintomas
crônicos há anos. Eu sabia interpretar
os resultados. Criamos um protocolo
específico baseado nos achados e não foi
um tiro no escuro, foi uma investigação
direcionada. Mas veja bem, se você tem
uma dorzinha de barriga de vez em quando
come mal e quer fazer o exame para ver
como está o intestino, geralmente nesses
casos não vale a pena. No momento atual
não parece haver evidência suficiente
para recomendar esses testes de rotina
paraa manutenção rotineira da saúde.
Então o Consenso Internacional de 2025
recomenda que a prescrição de um teste
microbioma deve ser feito por um
profissional de saúde licenciado,
médicos, farmacêuticos e nutricionistas,
mas não personal trainers, coaches,
homeopatas ou terapeutas nutricionais.
A autoprescrição por pacientes é
desencorajada. Então, outro detalhe
importante, muita gente faz o exame e
não sabe o que fazer com o resultado. É
como comprar um carro de fórmula um e
não saber dirigir. Então, como
microbiomas são altamente variáveis,
mesmo os normais e saudáveis, isso torna
incrivelmente desafiador definir os
padrões ou assinaturas que sugerem que o
microbioma se tornou desequilibrado.
Então a Maria, por exemplo, ela tinha
butirato normal no exame, mas era porque
ela estava tomando tributirina. Sem
saber interpretar isso, qualquer
profissional diria que estava tudo bem,
mas na verdade era uma máscara. o
intestino dela não estava provavelmente
produzindo botirato naturalmente. Agora,
quando o exame pode valer a pena, eu vou
ser bem claro. Se você tem doença
inflamatória intestinal diagnosticada
como doença de crom, retocolito serativa
ou síndrome intestino irritável e os
tratamentos convencionais não estão
funcionando. Isso vai ajudar a
personalizar o tratamento. Se você tem
sintomas gastrointestinais crônicos há
anos, já tentou múltiplos tratamentos,
não teve sucesso e o médico esgotou as
opções convencionais, seria ótima
indicação para esses exames. Se você tem
doenças autoimunes, problemas de pele
crônicos ligado ao intestino ou cílio do
intestino irritável, severa que não
responde a tratamentos. Se você vai
fazer o exame com profissional que
realmente entende microbioma e medicina
funcional, não adianta fazer, levar pro
médico que vai olhar e dizer
interessante e não saber o que fazer.
Quando não vale a pena. Então vamos ser
sinceros aqui. Se você quer fazer por
curiosidade, guarde os seus 3 a R$
4.000.
Se você tem sintomas leves, ainda não
tentou fazer o básico, né, de estilo de
vida, melhorar alimentação, reduzir
estress, dormir melhor, fazer exercício,
seria o mau investimento. Você acha que
o exame vai dar uma resposta mágica, né?
Mas para pessoas buscando respostas
hoje, a maior parte do microbioma ainda
é território inexplorado e tem valor
clínico limitado para ajudar pacientes
individuais. você não tem acompanhamento
profissional adequado, nesse caso, não é
bom fazer o exame. Fazer o exame sozinho
e tentar interpretar pelo Google vai ser
jogar dinheiro fora. Sabe qual é a
melhor forma de cuidar do seu microbioma
sem gastar uma fortuna? A melhor maneira
de apoiar o seu microbioma por enquanto,
seria você se alimentar com grande
variedade de plantas. Tente comer 30
plantas diferentes por semana. Uma
variedade de frutas, vegetais, legumes,
nozes, sementes, grãos integrais. ervas
especiarias. Isso funciona muito bem
para todo mundo e não precisa fazer
exame. No caso da Maria foi importante,
mostra que quando bem indicado,
interpretado, o exame pode mudar uma
vida. Então, identificamos problemas que
nunca teríamos achado de outra forma,
mas ela é exceção, não é a regra.
Pesquisadores prevêm um futuro onde
teste microbioma levem a ferramentas
analíticas preditivas que não sejam
redutíveis a ensaios simples, de forma
que o sequenciamento de nova geração com
computação avançada será cada vez mais
usado no laboratório de microbiologia
clínica, mas infelizmente esse futuro
ainda não chegou. O meu conselho final,
se você tem 3 a R$ 4.000 para investir
na sua saúde intestinal, comece pelo
básico. Compre comida de verdade,
orgânica, se for possível. Invista numa
consulta com médico funcional,
nutricionista funcional. Faça terapia
para reduzir o estress, melhore o sono,
tudo isso junto, não dá R$ 4.000, vai
fazer muito mais pelo seu intestino do
que o exame isolado. Agora, se você como
Maria tem sintomas prolongados,
crônicos, já tentou de tudo, tem um
profissional qualificado acompanhando,
aí sim pode ser um investimento que vai
mudar a sua vida. Mas seja realista.
Para 70% das pessoas que me perguntam, a
resposta é não, ainda não vale a pena.
Então o futuro é promissor, ferramentas
em microbiomas já mostram valor clínico
em cuidado, suporte, fibra dietética,
por exemplo, pode melhorar resultados de
quimioterapia, mas ainda estamos
aprendendo a usar essas informações da
forma prática. E lembre-se, o exame é
uma ferramenta, não é uma solução. No
caso da Maria, o exame foi só o começo.
O trabalho de verdade foi o protocolo
personalizado que criamos, o
acompanhamento mensal, os ajustes na
dieta, a suplementação específica, o
exame sem ação, é só um papel caro.
Então é isso, pessoal. Exame de
microbiota, ferramenta poderosa nas mãos
certas, desperdício de dinheiro nas mãos
erradas. Avalem a sua situação, sejam
honestos sobre suas necessidades e não
caiam em promessas milagrosas. Seu
intestino agradece e seu bolso também.